SPEAKER: Now I'm very excited
to welcome to Google Mark Z.
Danielewski.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK Z. DANIELEWSKI: Hello.
I thought I would read a
couple of short passages
from the familiar Volume
Three, and then we
can talk, have a conversation.
If no one wants to talk
or have a conversation,
I have plenty to
read here, so we
could fill the hour that way.
Some of you know this
is a 27-volume novel
about a little girl
who finds a cat.
And to avoid spoilers, I'm
going to read a little bit
from Xanther's
father's perspective,
and then-- actually, from
Xanther's mother's perspective,
and then I will
read a little bit
from her father's perspective.
So Astair is up
in a place called
Oceanica, where she is
training to be a therapist,
and she's in a class.
"'Is good thinking
terrifying?' Sandra D. Taylor,
their doula of Oceanica, asks
a room of 70 on Saturday,
August 9.
'Good thinking, I
like to think, is.
And I like to think about
it a great deal, too.
Though whether I manage any of
it is another story completely,
contested perhaps too
frequently by my grandchildren,
and gratefully by you.
Good thinking, I like to
think, is hard thinking.
And what makes hard thinking?'
Again, a genuine question.
'Consider this definition.
Hard thinking is
when we don't merely
apply preexisting rationales
to routine patterns.
For example, in the
way we might observe
events, note interactions,
evaluate emotional responses.
But instead acquire
a completely new set
of values and parameters to
reencounter and reinterpret
these common events,
interactions,
emotional responses.
'That's then one model
for hard thinking.
Hard because acquiring a new
set of values is hard work.
But is it terrifying?'
Astair has an answer,
but not the confidence
to voice it.
Her hangover isn't helping.
'Because our sense of
self, our identity--"
Did Sandra D. Just stare
directly at Astair?
Even linger there?
'Frequently find stabilization,
if not outright resolution,
in rationales inculcated
at an early age.
Examples, please.'
Hands shoot up,
though not Astair's,
followed by a clatter of voices.
'Catholicism,' 'Mormonism,'
'Judaism,' 'Islam,' 'party
affiliation,' 'sexual
orientation,' 'racial bias,'
'scientific method,' 'trbal
ritual,' 'taboo.' 'Good.
Religious rubrics, political
praxis, clan morals,
parental jurisprudence,
gender habits.
A long list, as we can
all agree, incomplete.
Changing any of those
modes of engagement
must necessitate a departure
from the original self, which
by the renegotiation can go so
far as to displace the self.
'And whether the
response is fatigue--
getting drowsy-- or boredom--
getting antsy-- or anger--
getting just that-- that is
most certainly terrifying.
Though isn't the
alternative worse?
To live many lives in heaven.
Hell is not to live even one.'
And that's just the beginning
Sandra D. Taylor speaks
for another 90 minutes, though
today for some reason Astair
stops taking notes.
There is a difference between
work that is constructive
and work that is compulsion.
Note the difference.
Beware the consequences
of not noting.
Working hard is not
the same as hard work.
Good work, good thinking,
even good living-- this
is what we pursue.
Which Astair remembers
perfectly, she thinks.
Even if her hand collapses
into some private,
inkless fugue of heaviness.
Her lids also engage
in the same heaviness,
even as some kind of
internal lid begins to open.
Somehow Sandra D.'s
talk demands it.
She says things like, 'Life
would be so wonderful if we
only knew what to do with it.
But why wonder?
Remember, no choice is
rendered any less significant
or impactful if made with
an even greater application
of kindness.'
Or, 'Think before you act,
then act without thinking.' Or,
'To find yourself again, go find
yourself in this world where
you are not of this world.
In other words, see new
places, meet new faces,
travel.' That one earns
much laughter and applause,
as many of her remarks do.
'Why keep escaping
from what makes us us?
As we are in a vocation
rooted in feelings,
let us not forget that
immaturity is frequently
reflected in the belief
that strong feelings ratify
every action.
In other words, and to be
prescriptive, let us be mature.
Remember, you future counselors
and bringers of relief,
there will never be a
cure for life's problems,
because so many of tomorrow's
problems will be new.
Good words like good
work and good thinking
help, even if good words are
a lot like highway paint--
they can keep plenty
of heavy things moving
at 70 miles per hour
from going the wrong way,
but that doesn't mean life
won't cross over if it has to.
Learn to avoid the collisions.'
'Find other directions.
Often a new yes is the best no.
Life lived well doesn't get
easier, but it does get better.
Learn to let things go by,
and don't be reluctant.
Life is always surpassing us by.
Enjoy it.'"
This is from
Anwar's perspective.
They are at a baseball game.
"Far below, a dodger,
number 10, swings his bat.
Even up here, the sound of
that wallop reaches them.
Anwar and Xanther rise
together with the whole stadium
it seems-- their
sections, at least.
Everyone's cheering.
Xanther and Anwar
sure are cheering.
It feels good.
The ball flies deep
into left field,
and with the peculiar magic of
a home run, seems to keep going,
during the night sky.
Xanther jumps up and down,
excitedly waving her Dodgers
hat, up on her seat, until
she jumps into Anwar's arms
with such big, excited hug.
And Anwar, lifting Xanther
up, holding her tight,
is suddenly missing his mother.
Out of nowhere, terribly,
she comes upon him
with all she ever
was-- her smile,
her kindness, her goodness.
How Anwar would have loved
to have seen Fatima here,
now with Xanther.
Would they have hugged too?
What would they have
said to each other later?
How would they have
teased and laughed
and sparred, together wondered?
Do we miss not only the
past, but every feature
the lost past describes?
Is that just the nature
of missing, all the lost
might-have-beens?
The certainty that those
uncertain futures are gone.
If we can't embrace uncertainty,
do we miss the point of love?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: So one of the
reasons I'm particularly
excited to have
you here at Google
is that-- you don't
really get a sense of it
from that Anwar section,
but there's actually
a lot of programmers and tech
people in "The Familiar".
I was just interested
what it was
like writing for the voices
of programmers and the tech
industry, whether you did any
sort of research for that?
MARK Z. DANIELEWSKI: Sure.
Well, one of the things is
that like, "House of Leaves"
is all about film, and
"Only Revolutions" is really
about music, and "The
Fifty Year Sword"
is about the campfire
tale, the oral tale.
"The Familiar" is very much
about a television series.
So every five volumes
makes up one season,
and there's a little
extra at the end.
And very much like
a television series,
it requires a great
deal of people.
So if you turn to the back
of any of the volumes,
you'll see a long
list of credits.
And that includes
engineers and people
that I've been-- that I reach
out to, to discuss code,
to discuss the environment
of tech companies.
And a lot of the book is about
getting outside of myself,
you know, of moving beyond that
authorial need to say, "I, I,"
all the time, and really
embrace-- empathize,
if you will-- mind read what a
very different perspective is
like.
So Anwar is
originally from Egypt,
and that history is slowly
beginning to open in the book.
But he's also a game developer.
And so it's really been great
hanging around with gamers,
hanging around with people
that are seeking VC money
to develop their latest
bit of entertainment.
But the fun part is that, as
I'm sure everyone in this room
can relate to, programmers
aren't just programmers.
They have a wonderful
sense of the world,
of the philosophical challenges.
And so as I begin
to sort of describe
what Anwar is up
against, and what
is beginning to change his
life, that sort of influences
the conversation.
So the coding then
begins to take
on a certain vocabulary that
is more than just functional,
it can have a symbolic value.
So even if we're
commenting out something,
those things can
not only resonate
on a sort of a literary
level, but they can also
contain obscure codes that
need to be sort of rendered
in a different way.
And if they are, if they
are looked at with that eye,
they can reveal more things.
Not only about the code,
but about the story itself.
SPEAKER: I'm going to have to
go back and reread some of those
now.
But in addition to
the tech characters,
there's also a lot of other ways
that technology finds itself
into the way a lot of
the sections of the book
are presented.
It can be introductory material.
We've seen sort of like a
YouTube video slowly playing
out.
We see parts of the
book told sort of
through messaging applications.
MARK Z. DANIELEWSKI: Right.
SPEAKER: So I'm interested
if the technology around us
today you feel
influences the way
you want to present
stories as a writer,
if it influences
the way you want
to communicate as a writer?
MARK Z. DANIELEWSKI: Sure.
I think it's-- I think my
attention has always been
there.
When "House of Leaves" came out,
there was very little emphasis
in the at least formal literary
world on typography and image
and graphics.
And yet that's something
that was already happening.
It preceded Instagram,
and Flickr, and Tumblr,
and all these things that
were sort of image-based.
And I think I grew
up in a time where
I watched this amazing,
kaleidoscopic shatter
of platforms that
one could invest
their creative or
social energies.
And I think the thing
that's exciting,
even though people have
their own domain, really,
of where they hang
out digitally,
they also sort of like to
experience other areas.
And those areas begin to kind
of influence their personality.
So the book itself encompasses
various perspectives
that aren't merely just
these characters, but also
the voice of technology
itself, the voice
of these various applications.
Whether it's the coding
within certain chapters,
or like you pointed out,
these YouTube moments.
They begin to sort of
create in one place
the sound of all of these
different views and voices
and hieroglyphs, I
guess, coming together.
SPEAKER: Interesting.
Neat.
By the way, if anyone
has any questions
they'd like to ask Mark, we've
got two microphones set up
in the aisles.
You're free to line
up there if there's
anything you want to know.
We can keep chatting
in the meantime.
So this is maybe more of an
abstract connection to Google,
but our mission is sort of all
about information, organizing
information and
collecting information.
And the way you
write your books,
there's a higher information
density than in typical books.
You find a way to
incorporate more information
on a word-by-word,
page-by-page basis.
Almost in the sense
that each book,
you have to learn to
read it in a new way.
Are you thinking
about, as you write it,
how someone is going to learn
to take in the information
that you're putting down,
that sort of learning process?
MARK Z. DANIELEWSKI:
Yeah, actually,
and that's something I did
from the very beginning.
In "House of Leaves" it was
sort of seen unapproachable.
But in fact, the way
the typography works
is there's a didactic
element, that it slowly
teaches the reader how
to embrace these turns
and changes.
And then by the end, the reader
is fluent in that language.
The same is true for
"Only Revolutions".
If you read it slowly and try to
read it like "House of Leaves",
or any other book,
you'll be miserable.
But if you embrace the speed
that Sam and Haley move
through history,
and read it quickly,
then you begin to
play that music,
and you begin to hear it.
"The Familiar" is very similar.
People struggle a
bit with Volume One.
And I was very surprised
on this book tour,
because here this 880-page book
just came out on June 14th,
and every city I went to,
those who'd read One and Two
had ripped through Volume Three
in like two days, because they
had already learned how to
read it, and it moved quickly.
There was enough familiarity
there, if you will,
that they could process
it much more rapidly.
And that's always been
the point, in a way,
is that every novel
requires an investment
of initial imagining.
Probably like any
platform, in a way,
establishing this foundation.
And that takes a lot of work.
But once that's there, then
you can move much more quickly
and adeptly around themes.
And so that's very
exciting, to see that work.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
And now that you're
on Volume Three--
and you've written ahead, right?
So you've sort of--
MARK Z. DANIELEWSKI: Four
is being proofed right now.
It will be finalized
by September 15th.
And then I get married
on September 17th.
It's going to be an
intense couple of months,
let me tell you.
SPEAKER: Wow.
So do you find that your
approach to writing now,
as the series has
progressed, has
changed from the first book?
Are you sort of learning
more about the story itself,
or has it sort of all
been plotted out already
and in stone?
MARK Z. DANIELEWSKI: Well, I
started work on "The Familiar"
in 2006, even though
there are many things that
even predate "House of Leaves".
But Volume One, for example,
had 100,000 words cut out of it.
So that's basically two
Great Gatsby's, you know?
And Volume Two was probably
about 60,000 or 50,000
that were cut.
And this one, you know, 30,000.
It would be great if I could
get it just right, but you know.
Yeah, it's a learning process.
Some things come easier,
then some things are harder.
Some of those details or whatnot
that need to be enhanced,
researched more, or whatnot.
But it's an exciting process,
as familiar as it all
is, it's still 10 years out.
And there's all
sorts of changes.
I think Google is kind
of is involved in that?
Isn't it about information,
preservation, the Long Now
movement?
Is that what it's called?
Anyone familiar with that?
Just how do we
preserve information
that can be viewed 10,000
years from now, or 100,000.
How will it be read?
And how can we prepare for
even an extraterrestrial
intelligence?
Even if that is our
intelligence that's radically
changed in thousands of years.
SPEAKER: Yeah, and I guess kind
of along with that, a new way
that your novels are
now being preserved
is through e-book format.
Which if someone were
to name any author who
I said their books could
never be done as an e-book,
you're probably right
at the top of that list.
So why was that choice made?
Or what was interesting
to you about trying
to adapt these things
into e-book format?
MARK Z. DANIELEWSKI:
Well, it's also--
part of it's an exploration.
I've backed a little away
from turning just-- creating
sort of enhanced versions.
Because it's such a lot of work.
And I've often
said that it would
be great to have
directors who were really
responsible for transforming
books into electronic versions,
because it's its own art form.
There's many ways that
one can present it.
The e-book for all
of these volumes
is exactly what the
page is, so there's
no-- there hasn't been any
sort of radical modifications.
But as I understand it,
even with that availability,
it's a small percentage
of readers who tackle
"The Familiar" on an iPad.
People like the book.
They like the technology
of what's there.
I mean even as I was
doing various readings,
people would come up
and they would go,
I know where you were.
I knew it was an Anwar chapter.
I know what Anwar's
dog-ear colors are,
so I could approximate
and find the place.
And so they've
already learned how
to use the book to quickly
move, to navigate through it.
And that's also exciting.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
It was very interesting hearing
that, both of those chapters
read out, Anwar and
Astair's, verbally.
Because on the page,
things are set up
very differently than you
hear them as they're read.
I've also-- I read stuff online.
It seems like it's been one
of the hotly debated topics
of the book, is
sort of the nesting
of the parentheses and stuff.
So I'm interested where
that idea came from,
what interested you about seeing
these thoughts within thoughts
within thoughts?
MARK Z. DANIELEWSKI: Right.
So Astair's thoughts are nested
with all these parentheses.
It's very difficult to write.
And Anwar's are nested with all
sorts of-- with some computer
coding, but also
a lot of brackets.
But they're similar
in many ways.
They're a
hyper-intellectual couple,
and they want-- or their
children carry that out
to a certain degree.
But at the same time,
they're also restrained.
So it's about how
thoughts can get caged,
how they can open cages
by becoming more specific.
And when readers
first encounter it,
they're like, oh,
this is a nightmare.
And then they hear me read an
Astair bit, and they're like,
oh, all those parentheses
are just commas.
It's like, that's the
way she experiences
those momentary pauses,
but another person
may just experience what could
be a total meltdown of thinking
as just a pause, as a breath.
SPEAKER: Any questions from
you Googlers out there?
Oh, cool.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
So I didn't realize when
I started reading Volume
One that it was 27 volumes.
Maybe I just skipped over that.
And it sort of
quixotically, maybe-- I
think that is the
right word-- now
makes me want to
read all of them
more, because I know that
when Volume Three is over
there's still 24 left, right?
So that's exciting.
I've also noticed, because
I read a lot of books,
and I shop for a
lot of books-- I do
tend to use an
application on the iPad
to do it-- that that seems
like a direction that
is more commercially viable
these days, to sort of-- you
know, you're looking through
the best-sellers on Amazon
or whatever, in the e-book
section, and about half of them
will say like, Book Two of
the Shadow Pets Tetralogy,
or whatever.
So I'm just curious how
much of your motivation
was commercial, or is
it purely ambitious?
Just like a desire to make
something that's really huge,
or what went into that?
How did you know
that it was going
to be 27 books, et cetera?
MARK Z. DANIELEWSKI:
Great question.
I did-- I mean again, I was
working on this in 2006.
I started wearing cat t-shirts.
Cats were not that
popular online, you know?
I was envisioning this
long, long series.
The series hadn't
really taken hold yet
the way-- "The Sopranos"
was sort of in the air,
and then "The Wire" was coming.
But now we have
just all stations
are flooded with these
kind of chaser series.
So I'm either right on time,
or I'm a little too late.
We'll see.
But you can't undertake
a book like this,
which really is
without precedent--
I mean you can point
to serial novels,
you can point to series--
but a book that embraces
a real-time pacing
and that is set out
with a very specific
narrative arc-- it's not
a performative bit of
invention-- is very risky,
really.
Because the series, like
a television series,
could get canceled
at any moment.
But what really holds me
is I love these characters.
I love this family.
I love the story.
I love giving voice to
those who I don't know,
and getting to know them.
And then moving
beyond voice to begin
to allow into the sphere of the
way we understand the world,
the way the world
understands itself.
The conversation between
storm fronts and mountain
ranges, where is
that in how we live.
We can't be blinded
constantly by ourselves.
And as soon as you
really open up,
when you let these
walls dissolve
into the atomic
miracle that it is,
that we can be so aware
of it momentarily,
then 27 volumes
seems pretty paltry.
SPEAKER: Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
It's a quick question.
So before-- this goes back to,
I guess, "House of Leaves",
and I think you just
answered the question
that I had in my mind just
now for "The Familiar".
But early on, before I actually
read "House of Leaves",
I had heard the book described
as one of the scariest books
ever written.
So I went into it with
that sort of mindset.
And I'm curious as to if
that was your intention,
or what was the mood that you
were trying to convey when you
were writing that book, or when
you thought the reader would
actually absorb it?
MARK Z. DANIELEWSKI: Do
you remember who told you
it was the scariest book?
AUDIENCE: It was on some online
thread, probably on Reddit.
MARK Z. DANIELEWSKI: We have
to wonder about that person.
The book is designed,
I guess, to give room--
to provide room for
the reader's fears.
So really, it's-- I meet
people who were just very happy
in that house,
and I thought, oh,
you're really happy
with yourself.
So in many ways, as with all
my books, it's really about,
where is the reader's
place in this relationship?
And I think as much as there
is something scary about "House
of Leaves", it is
really about a journey.
And I'll tell you,
one of the things that
just keeps coming up, and it is
strange and kind of wonderful,
is that I get so many
notes from people
who have been going
through hard times
and find that this book
offers them relief.
People who've actually
tried to kill themselves,
and said that this
book offered them
a way through the darkness.
So I think maybe the
intention-- and it's
complicated to talk
about an intention
when you worked on something for
so long, that is so complex--
but it was actually about
that, the journey of the self,
and how we do
parse the darkness.
And yeah, so I think of--
I think of all my books,
but they're like my
children, and they grow up,
and they have these
very intimate relations
with strangers.
And I'm like the dad, and
I've got to kind of stay out
of the picture, because no
one wants the dad hanging out.
I think one of the best
compliments I ever got
was there was a class in
the Midwest, I think it was,
and it was, Faulkner,
David Foster Wallace,
and "House of Leaves".
And that was great, you know?
I don't need to be
in that picture.
And so the relationship that
people have with the book
is what I'm proud of, and
so I think it's a good kid.
So you know, I'm sorry it
scared your online friend,
but maybe he or she needed it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I had a question
about mechanics.
I know "House of Leaves"
comes with a set of mechanics
that you learn as you read
through it, one being like,
trust the footnotes that they're
not going to misguide you,
you'll find your way back.
And you even mention with "Only
Revolutions" the speed of it,
getting you into the story.
As somebody who's not yet
dove into "The Familiar",
is there some advice
that you could
give on the mechanics of
actually reading the book?
And as a slight
follow-up to that,
I know "Only Revolutions" had
a lot of fun little Easter
eggs that were stuck in, word
count per page kind of thing.
Are there some Easter
eggs for "The Familiar"
that a new reader
should look out for?
MARK Z. DANIELEWSKI:
Great question.
You know I'm not
going to answer it.
Why would I want to deprive you
of all that fun of uncovering
the mechanics for yourself?
I mean we've got 27 volumes.
We might as well just sort
of settle back and go, huh,
wait a minute,
maybe Volume Four,
suddenly there's a
certain kind of symmetry
that presents itself, and
then you figure that out.
If I were Will
Shortz-- and I'm not--
I wouldn't be up here telling
you all those answers.
But let's just
say that you won't
be disappointed if you look.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
earlier about working
with a lot of other
people on the book,
and just what that
collaboration was like.
But I know on
"House of Leaves" it
was a different kind of
collaboration with your sister,
how her music overlapped
the book and the book
overlapped the music.
So I'm wondering what
that process was like,
and whether you had any plans to
do something similar like that
with "The Familiar".
MARK Z. DANIELEWSKI: Right.
When we were working
together, it seemed obvious
that we would do that forever.
I mean it was so incredible
how everything aligned.
She was working on
her CD, "Haunted",
I was working on
"House of Leaves".
She would read parts, and that
would influence her music.
I would listen to
her tracks and that
would influence
"House of Leaves",
and it went back and forth,
very much like the Escher hands
drawing each other.
Some people say that
"Haunted" is Poe's soundtrack
to "House of Leaves".
That is not at all correct.
It was as much a progenetor
as it was an offspring.
We were both in this
curious, creative orbit.
And it was fantastic.
Even the way they
were both finished,
that came out at the
same time, in essence,
that they were launched
in the same way.
I mean I don't even
know if you could
launch a musical work like
hers in the same way today.
It was a different industry.
Like a book, the CD
came out, and then there
was a tour, and all of that.
And it was really special.
It would be amazing to do
something like that again,
but who knows.
To get all those stars
to line is complicated.
And I guess we got a
little sense of it,
and I hope this doesn't
happen at Google,
but my book had just
come out in Japan.
And I think it was maybe
a-- it was a smaller house,
but it was owned by Sony.
And her CD was being
released by Sony.
So this was a perfect
opportunity for Sony
just to take a look at
both these works in Japan.
They could not coordinate that.
It was so strange.
It was this huge
company that kind of
couldn't get one hand to
interact with the other.
And I think that's just the
reality, just where our lives
are and what we're
pursuing, to actually get
all of that to align.
But she did have
some tracks that
were very influential
on "Only Revolutions",
and if she releases
them one day,
then there might
be that little aha
moment for readers out
there, when they go,
oh, that's where he got that.
She really is the
smart one, isn't she?
SPEAKER: Anyone else?
Awesome.
Well, Mark, maybe
before we wrap up,
do you have time for one more
passage from "The Familiar"?
MARK Z. DANIELEWSKI: Yeah.
I was almost thinking
I should reread them.
It was such a disaster.
You could edit it, or something.
Yeah, let's read another one.
SPEAKER: Great.
All right.
One last passage from Mark
Danielewski, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
"Astair doesn't even realize
how tight her chest has gotten--
like a man's fist,
she imagines--
until she steps outside.
Something about the
dinginess offends her.
Astair isn't even thinking of
the jeans and the boxers hucked
over the hair-matted sofa, or
the muddy boots on the coffee
table.
She's thinking about all of it.
The stink, for sure.
For sure.
"She sneezes now twice more.
Her throat itches.
Eyes, too.
Allergies?
"Still better than the
way she felt inside.
Flushed, envious.
Something's at her feet.
Can she even call it a cat?
What a grizzled thing.
Gray with just a glint
of green in one eye.
The other eye is marble white.
Ick.
"The ear above the ick?
It's no more than
a hole surrounded
by spidery threads of flesh.
The whole left side is
nothing more than a few tufts
of ashen hair, except where
there is no hair at all.
A substantial trench
digs alongside the spine
through the ribs and
down into the rear flank,
rendering a back
leg pretty useless.
The tail is just gone.
"Nonetheless, this
tortured thing rubs
against Astair's ankle,
even after she recoils.
Its mew, or is a purr, a harsh
grate of improbable survival,
only stops when nearby--
very nearby, just up the hill
crowned in brush-- something
else unleashes its thunder.
"Astair feels gripped
by the bones, the teeth.
'What the fuck was that?' What
Astair has every intention
of asking Kochelle as she's
letting herself through the big
gate, only to freeze at the
sight of the three Australian
shepherds, Gus and
Vito and Juneau,
frozen before that
last big cage.
Something about that
cage now beginning
to dawn on Astair, along
with, 'Where is Kochelle?
Where is Xanther?'
"Dark shapes moving inside.
Way, way bigger than dogs.
Not dogs at all.
Astair is sprinting,
breath quickening,
already breathing way too hard,
until she's not even breathing.
Another fist in her chest, this
one of a much different kind,
as Astair reaches the fencing
to discover yellow eyes
and swirls of black
fur, and teeth clicking
in a low guttural growls.
Wolves, five of them.
And all circling frantically,
and shaking their heads,
repeatedly lunging
out suddenly to snap,
before withdrawing just as
fast to continue circling.
"And the center of
their attention?
The object of these attacks?
Her baby girl, sitting
cross-legged, alone.
Until adrenaline sharpens
Astair's perceptions--
Kochelle's in there,
too, with a baton,
but cornered by
the biggest wolf.
"No, not the biggest.
The biggest has just clamped
its jaws on her daughter's arm,
twisting to rip it away, rip
it off, tear Xanther apart.
'Mom!' Xanther cries.
"Which is when
everything goes messy.
Adrenaline misplaced,
gushing for nowhere now,
against conflicting
sights and tones.
Saliva returns to
Astair's mouth.
The beating in her chest slows
as her body starts to relax,
even if her mind persists in
trying to command all of her
to keep tensing, tense still
more, do something more.
Dammit.
"'Mom,' Xanther cries again.
'Come in!' Kochelle
looks just as happy.
That second biggest
wolf before her,
a blur of charcoal
and snow, has just
rolled over, wanting something
from Kochelle-- to play with?
While the biggest
wolf with Xanther,
a blonde billow of heavy
shoulders and bright eyes,
continues to rip away at
what's only a frayed blanket,
red, which Xanther
playfully withholds until,
overpowered, she lets
go with a squeal.
'Aren't they amazing?'
"They are.
But they think
she's more amazing.
Kochelle notices it,
too, especially when
Xanther stands up.
Immediately Kochelle's
attendant, attendant wolf
wheels around to
rejoin the pack, fallen
behind the blonde alpha, who
pays no mind to the rest,
paying close attention only
to every move Xanther's
12-year-old makes.
"Only Xanther is
oblivious, practically
skipping across the cage
to meet Astair at the gate.
The blonde alpha drops
his prized blanket
to keep close to Xanther-- too
close-- teeth nearly knicking
those fragile heels, even as the
pack hangs back, if still tuned
to the flitting motion
of Xanther's hands,
her bobbing head
and dancing knees,
as if they soon might earn
some anticipated reward.
"'She's special,'
Kochelle says later,
after Xanther goes off
to find the bathroom.
'I'm partial,' Astair
responds, her practiced tone
of neutrality in effect.
'You start together,' Kochelle
continues in her tone leaking
with confession,
or just curiosity.
"'That's the way you're
supposed to start,
because I mean they know me.
And then you sit
down so you're lower
than them, or the same
height but not higher,
which would make you
maybe more leader-ish,
and definitely more
of an outsider.
But when you're
down low, then they
treat you like part of the pack.
And they come around
and sniff you, and even
pull at the blanket I
let your daughter hold.
"'And then you stand up like
I stood up, to be leader-ish,
see?
And I kind of moved away,
which is when they usually
all follow me.
Except this time only
Montana followed me,
and it was like--'
Kochelle's smile changes.
'Huh.
It was like he wasn't
really following, but more
trying to separate me and,
you know, keep me away.
Kind of like the way
someone might do at a party,
pull someone away
so the rest can
have a private conversation.
Actually, now that I think
about it, it was really weird.'
"Astair's heart is at it
again, adrenaline back, too,
except this time,
instead of confusion,
it's all about anger.
Kochelle has no clue.
'They just took to her,'
the young woman continues.
'I mean took to her.
Did you see at the
end, how she got up
and they fell back
like all at once,
and Montana left me quick, and
like even Quasar, the alpha,
healed behind her?
I've worked with them
for three years now,
and they never do that for me.
Not even toys,' Kochelle
whispered that last part.
"'Not in that way.
It's like they knew her.
Like she was one of them.
Or all of them.
I mean but in charge, you know?'
Kochelle suddenly chuckles,
loud and abrasively.
'Man, I must be beat.
Sounds like I'm calling
your kid a werewolf.'
"Before Kochelle
leaves, still clueless,
she again announces
that [INAUDIBLE]
is only minutes away.
Traffic.
Xanther and Astair are welcome
to hang out with the dogs
or kick back in
mini barn office.
With Xanther out of earshot
back by the monkeys,
Kochelle also asks,
soto voce, too,
that Astair 'not
mention, you know,
that thing with the wolves.
There's supposed to be all this
release of liability paperwork
to fill out, and anyhow, you
know your daughter, right?'
"Astair tries to crush
every answer, only one
between her teeth, grinding away
like she so often tells Xanther
not to do, though
something in her expression
still betrays her.
Kochelle's eyes widen,
her youth suddenly
too evident on
her soft features.
'You do know I didn't
take her in there, right?
I was feeding Havoc.
She was talking to them and
then she just walked in.'
"Later, long after Kochelle's
dirty white Corolla
left in spectres of dust,
what Astair keeps turning over
in her head is not
this revelation,
but a different warning.
Xanther had returned from the
bathroom slightly spooked.
'What's up the hill?'
'Yeah,' Kochelle untensed.
'Don't go up there, OK?
Please, don't.'" Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]